[Music]  it took me three weeks of ass kissing  just to get into one  good thing  dumb dumb dumb dumb 151 run a blunt  young legendary tour  we're going to seven parties tonight bro  you should take it easy don't get cool  into any trouble for boys black  excellence  we only gonna have five minutes when we  get back to pre-game change  where's carlos  there's an unconscious white girl in our  living room  [Music]  okay okay she's alive we should call 911  they just gonna come in here and see  three brown guys hanging over this  little white girl we looked everywhere  and we can track her on your phone  we can't just leave her somewhere we  take her to the hospital  [Applause]  i told you we should just call 911.  the hell is going on we don't know who  she is actually she just told me that  she's in high school  [Applause]  think about it statistically  how many people actually get shot by the  cops it's like really really unlikely  right  yummy  [Music]  you